this video is sponsored by hellofresh
food we all need it but do we really
have any idea what we're doing the other
day I'm pretty sure I ate nothing other
than pizza and I wonder why I have
trouble with energy not to mention most
of us are out in the world eating out
every meal and that's not easy on your
health or your wallet but fortunately
for people like me hello fresh is the
hero we need they deliver healthy less
than a week old farm fresh ingredients
alongside extremely easy to follow
recipes in a box to your door so that
you can whip up some pretty awesome
meals all of which are healthier for you
more affordable than daily fast food and
much quicker and less stressful than
shopping at a grocery store they were
kind enough to send me pork tostadas
onion crunch chicken and firecracker
meatballs all of which I have cooked and
enjoyed but my favorite was the
meatballs because beef is my first love
and listen not to humblebrag but do you
see how professional I look in these
shots I mean damn I look like a chef or
something and I'm just a video game guy
with their easy to follow recipes and
instructions if I can do it literally
anybody can it's foolproof and delicious
and their meals are fully customizable
from collecting different dietary
options like carb friendly or vegetarian
to swapping proteins and sides and I
could rattle on but I'll just skip to
the best part if you go to
hellofresh.com use the code banditgame65
for 65 percent off plus free shipping
yeah save yourself even more money and
time and get yourself healthy no matter
your dietary needs do it you'll thank me
later and now on to the video
a Zelda game without Ganon is actually
kind of typical which is pretty weird to
think about because even though
technically speaking Ganon is the
original Zelda villain from a real life
perspective he's not the original
villain when it comes to in-game lore
and he's only present in like half of
the games but that aside clearly Ganon
is the most recognizable zeld villain of
them all and one of the most well-known
in gaming as a whole not only due to the
fact that he did originate from the
first game in the 80s but also because
he's just plain cool and ironically is
one of the famous chosen three who
received the power of the Triforce at
several different points in the series
this depth makes him stand out as a
unique villain and in this video I'm
going to explain the lore behind every
appearance of Ganon throughout the
series oh and spoiler alert obviously
the first things that I'm going to
tackle are a couple of burning questions
that some of you no doubt have the first
of which would be what is the difference
if any between Ganon and Ganon Dwarf
what a great question I'm so glad you
asked Ganondorf although not present in
the series until the fifth game in the
French franchise Ocarina of Time
actually comes before Ganon as far as
lore is concerned what I mean by that is
that Ganondorf the Gerudo human being
was first and then transformed into
Ganon via the power of the Triforce of
power now this is slightly theoretical
and you're more than welcome to disagree
with me because of that as is your
prerogative when discussing things not
directly confirmed in game but my
understanding is that Ganon is the
Demonic Beast form that Ganondorf
transforms into when augmented by a
great power source such as the Triforce
or the Twilight or malice and this
explanation for ganon's existence is
what I'll be branching off of for the
entirety of this video the second
burning question that you may have is
what do I mean every cannon in the
series isn't there just one well yes but
also no most ganons are actually the
same yes just split up by different
timelines and appear differently
depending on multiple different factors
however one Ganon in particular is
actually a straight-up reincarnation and
therefore another Ganon entirely you see
in the child timeline which we'll get
back to at some point later in the video
Ganondorf is killed straight up but then
another Ganondorf is born at some point
in the future and eventually transforms
into another Ganon and subsequently gets
sealed away at the end of four Swords
Adventures that being said each
appearance whether the same Ganon slash
dwarf or not will be covered in full
detail so just hang tight the last
question to tackle before getting into
the nitty-gritty would be the question
of whether or not Ganon is the literal
Reincarnation of demise's hatred which
as many people will remember is the
beginning of the seemingly endless cycle
of Good vs Evil that we see happen in
every Zelda game my answer to that is no
Ganon is not the literal incarnation of
demise's hatred at least not directly
he's more of a byproduct see a lot of
people including me formally assume that
Ganon is the demon that demises Eternal
hatred manifests as but that explanation
doesn't allow for the existence of other
demon Kings and Lords such as malidis or
Majora which also embody the hatred of
demise instead I now believe that demise
simply cursed his hatred into a
reincarnating existence in the exact
same way that link or the spirit of the
hero reincarnates and similarly to the
spirit of the hero will always
reincarnate as an individual that may
then become augmented and turn into a
demon this automatically explains every
major demon in every major antagonist
such as vati or Ganondorf or the other
Ganondorf because once one of them dies
another will eventually reincarnate due
to the curse just like another link will
eventually reincarnate due to the
blessing if you will yet another
similarity and parallelism between hylia
and demise but that's enough talking
about not Ganon and ganon's own video so
let's move on according to prophecy that
was set in place an unknown time ago by
forces currently unknowable the desert
dwelling Gerudo people give birth to a
male child only once every hundred years
and once of age that boy is by default
to become the king of the Gerudo this
was the age-old custom of the grudo
until one particular boy was born in
crowned King and his name was Ganondorf
he was born long ago before the events
of Ocarina of Time and is introduced to
us in-game as the the Gerudo King who
apparently swore allegiance to the king
of Hyrule however as Zelda correctly
predicted this Allegiance was fake and
ganondorf's true intent was to find and
seize the Triforce for himself which was
under the protection of the royal family
of Hyrule and that's the only backstory
to Ganondorf that we had all the way
until his appearance in the Wind Waker
when we finally were able to realize the
deeper reasoning behind his actions
which put simply he did out of jealousy
as the ruler of the Gerudo he knew
firsthand of all the hardships that come
with living in the desert and he wanted
the land of Hyrule for his own because
of this however instead of acting nobly
and perhaps collaborating somehow with
the king of Hyrule to alleviate the
harsh living conditions of his people he
instead sought to usurp the Throne of
Hyrule forcefully and take its
omnipotent Triforce for his own no
matter his reasoning though he
eventually did discover the Triforce and
upon attempting to touch it split it
apart into the three pieces of power
wisdom and courage which rested within
Ganondorf Zelda and Link respectively
for seven long years he searched for the
other two pieces while sitting at top
his stolen Throne of Hyrule and
eventually link brings both himself and
Zelda to ganondorf's front door after
being defeated by Link in combat
Ganondorf calls upon the power of the
Triforce of power within him and
transforms into a hideous demon
introducing the world to the monster
known as Ganon the effects and Legacy of
which we have yet to escape to this day
it's also worth mentioning that ever
since ganondorf's Reign Over the Gerudo
and transformation into the Demon King
Ganon the Gerudo people have officially
sworn off all males assumedly including
their own it's confirmed that there have
been no Kings since Ganondorf but it's
unknown as to whether or not there have
still been other Gerudo men born but
back to Ganon as a side note for what
it's worth I think that Phantom ganons
are named Phantom Ganon instead of
phantom Ganon Dwarf even though they
directly look like Ganondorf instead of
Ganon because Ganon is also the term we
use for Magical doppelgangers of
Ganondorf if you will that's really
neither here nor there but I just wanted
to take a moment and explain my thought
process since technically Phantom ganons
are you know ganon's at least in name
but back to Ganon Ganon as you know
following the events of Ocarina of Time
the timeline splits into three separate
ones the adult which follows the events
pictured here the child which follows
the events pictured here and the Fallen
which follows events we don't see
actually since it's more of an alternate
reality where Ganon manages to defeat
Link in each of these timelines we see
Ganon again but notably in vastly
different appearances in the adult
timeline he appears again as a puppet
something unable to move on its own in
the child timeline he appears as a
four-legged beast and is the only time
he appears this way in the entire series
aside from breath of the wild and in the
Fallen timeline he appears similarly to
his original Ocarina of Time appearance
as a two-legged humanoid Pigman monster
thing now I happen to believe that the
differing appearances are no coincidence
at all and allow me to explain in the
first place I don't think the Ganon
transformation is reversible at least
the Ganon that Ganondorf transforms into
I think the only times we see Ganondorf
transform into Ganon and then back into
Ganondorf are specifically occasions
where link is able to kill Ganon such as
at the end of our creative time or
Twilight Princess in both of these
circumstances Ganondorf still had the
Triforce of power in his possession
which likely prevented him from
completely dying after link does
something like this now I know some of
you will immediately think about the
ending scene of Twilight Princess where
Ganondorf still having the Triforce of
power inside him still ends up dying but
I've already concocted an entire theory
about that subject exactly which I will
not explain here for lack of time so if
you're interested check out my video on
that exact subject which will be linked
below anyway if we think about it this
way as in if Ganon is a permanent
transformation unless defeated this
would automatically explain each
differing appearance puppet Ganon from
Wind Waker strangely appears as a
lifeless puppet and after being defeated
it's revealed that it truly was not
Ganondorf after all and in fact the real
Ganondorf had been chilling on top of
the giant chandelier thing controlling
puppet Ganon the whole time so let's
imagine for a moment that since Wind
Waker takes place after the events at
the end of Ocarina of Time in the adult
timeline where link kills Ganon that
form can no longer be transformed into
because of this Ganondorf who has been
making several Phantom ganons in the
game creates a final Phantom Ganon that
transforms into puppet Ganon which
Ganondorf controls directly instead of
actually transforming into it himself by
contrast in the child timeline which
takes place before Ganondorf was ever
able to transform into Ganon in the
first place at the end the Gerudo King
calls upon the power of the Twilight to
accomplish several things such as
possessing Princess Zelda and after
being squeezed out of her transforming
into dark Beast Ganon which by the way
is the only other four-legged Ganon
aside from the Ganon in breath of the
wild who's also referred to as the dark
Beast Ganon almost as if to imply that
they are different Transformations
because they transformed due to
different power sources Twilight and
Malice and the reason he transformed
into more of a beast in Twilight
Princess is in my opinion the same
reason that link transforms into a wolf
in the same game it's due to the
exposure to Twilight since both link and
Ganondorf have triforces in their
systems and Link transforms into a wolf
exposed why not Ganondorf into a wolf
Pig thing and after his defeat is Ganon
he de-transforms into a ball of pure
energy does battle with midna then
appears in Hyrule Field as Ganondorf
once again with dark Beast Ganon dead
and gone at this point never to be seen
again later on in the timeline following
ganondorf's death at the end of Twilight
Princess another Ganondorf is born and I
know four Swords Adventures lore is kind
of messy because of this but hey it's
Canon and it's on the timeline right
here so it's got to have some sort of
explanation which is that demises hatred
once again reincarnates as another
Ganondorf but this time he transforms
into Ganon via unknown means it can be
assumed though that he transformed
because he obtained the Trident but like
I said it's unclear since you really
don't see Ganon or Ganondorf at all in
the game and the Triforce is nowhere to
be seen anyway in the alternate reality
called the Fallen timeline Ganondorf
transforms into Ganon but is actually
able to kill link however due to link
having already awakened the sages and
according to the intro of A Link to the
Past Ganon was stopped by the Sage's aka
the wise men and sealed away within the
sacred realm along with the full
Triforce which implies that he also
retrieved the Triforce of wisdom from
Zelda following Link's death well
actually that bit right there is a
little bit of a head cannon from me what
a link to the past actually says
happened is Ganondorf just straight up
murdered all his minions so that he
alone could enter the sacred realm and
grab the Triforce for himself
successfully Wishing Upon it to rule the
world and corrupting the sacred realm
into the dark world it's a bit
contradictory though in several places
since it says that Ganondorf actually
was able to wish upon the Triforce which
means that for some reason the Triforce
wish worked instead of splitting apart
like it did when he tried to wish upon
it in Ocarina of Time and also it
implies the door to the sacred realm was
open and that Ganondorf then transformed
into Ganon inside the realm and was
sealed within it if this were true then
link would have still woken up seven
years later since he was asleep at this
time and likely would have you know done
something about the situation since it
literally is contradictory and actually
seems to reference events not linked to
Ocarina of Time I choose to personally
explain the Fallen timeline as link
being eliminated at the final battle of
Ocarina of Time and then the events that
A Link to the Past happens afterwards
but you can believe whatever you wish As
It ultimately doesn't matter much for
explaining the existence of Ganon the
point is his Triforce powered
transformation was into a two-legged
humanoid pig monster when he's defeated
for the first time at the end of a link
to the past the Triforce is not present
within him so he actually does die
completely he's halfway resurrected
again in the events of the Oracle games
via his surrogate mother's twin rova
although the resurrection is interrupted
by link and only a Mindless Ganon is
revived and subsequently killed later on
in A Link Between Worlds Yuga
specifically harnesses the power of the
seven maidens who are the descendants of
the wise men aka the sages to resurrect
and transform into Ganon or in this case
Yuga Ganon and of course is killed once
again by the hero of Hyrule and once
again later on in the timeline prior to
the events of the original Legend of
Zelda game Ganon is once again revived
by his lingering followers and leads an
assault against Hyrule in order to
obtain the Triforce of wisdom which
Zelda has broken and Scattered across
the land preemptively Ganon is once
again killed by link and technically
revived again in the next game Zelda 2
The Adventure of link if link dies
that's a big if though but I mean hey
maybe it spawns another Fallen timeline
off of the Fallen timeline so the fall
and Fallen timeline yeah that makes
sense with ganon's many different
appearances throughout the timelines
explained it's time to talk about his
latest appearances as Calamity Ganon and
dark Beast Ganon in breath of the wild
right off the bat and trust me I'm not
copping out of explaining it I'm just
avoiding full-on speculation by
admitting that it's hard to explain the
specifics of ganon's appearance here due
to breath of the wild not officially
connecting to any one of the previous
timelines and of course theories can be
made but this is not a timeline Theory
video so I digress the one thing that
carries over across all the timelines
though is the hatred of demise and what
I can say is that by the time of breath
of the wild Ganon is more of an idea
than an actual being that resurfaces
eternally sometimes spanning 10 000
years in between appearances and that
both Calamity Ganon and dark Beast Ganon
and heck even the blight ganons are all
made of the same goopy evil substance
referred to as malice none of which are
actual transformations of Ganondorf like
the other ganons from the timelines but
rather are puppets if you will or
perhaps Phantoms that are all
manifesting outside ganondorf's corpse
he's been able to make Phantom ganons
before but it always used to be either
due to Gerudo dark magic or the power of
the Triforce of power so the real
question we should be asking is what is
malice specifically and where does it
come from I know people will immediately
say that malice as a substance has ties
way back to Skyward Sword in that it's
heavily implied that that's what
monsters are made out of in that game
but ganondorf's not a monster right he's
human or he was at some point so where
did the malice come from well with tears
of the Kingdom right around the corner I
think this very question is about to get
an answer and therefore Calamity Ganon
will finally be fully explained we
already know that it looks like malice
is coming from ganondorf's Corpse but
again he didn't used to ooze reddish
purple jelly out of his chest so
something must have changed maybe an old
foe was returning from their Eternal
Slumber and needs a physical body to
possess but before we dive headfirst
into speculation station I'm gonna go
ahead and pump the brakes there thank
you so much for watching and if you
enjoyed the video or at least my efforts
into making it please consider leaving a
like as it helps the video performance
greatly And subscribe to my channel if
you haven't yet because really if you're
still here you should be subscribed you
like my videos admit it and I'll admit I
like having you here too also if you're
planning on picking up the game you'll
want to be here trust me and you can
always unsub later huge thanks as always
to my Bandit crew of which I have the
name of minduino to introduce you're all
so wonderful and Bandit loves you very
much that's all for this one so be sure
to follow me on my socials and I'll see
you next time this is Bandit signing out
[Music]